on this episode we talk mcdonald's vs.
Burger King and what do I need to be
doing more of
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
Gary B so that's the response right
Jesus Christ this was really well done
they should have made a day in march
called natural burger peace day yeah and
made it a different thing and not
associated themselves with a UN sanction
holiday the microsite for burger
Oh a lot of people gave the first
response like as the most is bad well it
speaks like it speaks to like people
caring about fluffy issues not the real
issue
yeah look it's also one of those issues
where you just like it depends on what
side of the bed you wake up on like all
of us equally like don't want like the
amount of insane [ __ ] going on in the
world it's just so it's overwhelming for
an individual human being like I was
retired yesterday we went to like the
Bowery to like start an uprising with
the homeless like like like like you
know like like it's just like literally
all night I'm like you know like why
can't my chemical switch and like will
there ever be a day where I don't want
to buy the Jets and I want to solve this
will will something bad happen in my
family that makes me literally the next
day wake up and say that's it I'm curing
drunk driving instead of like buying the
Jets and then and then also equally
knowing that way too many people are
full of [ __ ] and I'm like I care about
solving drunk driving but don't really
like like I'm like I think that's what
my whole MO is which is like I'm just
like I like right hooks I didn't right
jab jab jab which is how everybody wants
to sell social media which is like the
deeper layer thing it's super
interesting you should make this video
just all of us no I want this to be a
video in itself yeah I just really want
that to be I'll actually yeah let's do
it though okay here we go
you could go black and white on this
whole thing too and just keep it in the
show you rock you can make the creative
decision on that
everybody am welcome to wine library TV
that's right keep this d-roc everybody
says gary vay-ner-chuk and this is
episode 134 on the ask gary vee show
that was interesting the brain is a very
powerful device I really am a curious
how you're gonna roll with all of this
d-roc back in the saddle a lot of people
behind me today which makes me happy
that's always good to see the Vayner
family in full effect in august a lot of
companies checking out right now looks
like the Manor media crew is doing their
thing that makes me proud and happy I'm
supposed to be on vacation what the hell
I'm doing here and so that's that
excited about the show today appreciate
everybody who jumped into yesterday's
show I know came out late so you may be
seeing this and not realize one snuck in
yesterday you're like where's 143 it
happened and so that said India so India
let's get into the show yeah you drilled
it tasha asks do you take on any client
if the price is right
or do you turn down base on your values
and beliefs so this has been interesting
we've been having some interesting
situations happening at vaynermedia
where I would say that well East Coast
and West Coast political correctness
bias over certain clients has been
rearing its head at vaynermedia and I've
been really struggling actually quite a
bit lately on what I don't want to be
the judge and jury of vaynermedia's
moral compass on which clients we take
and so I'm trying to figure out if it's
legal in America should that be the line
in the sand it's a great question we
have you know I've been this is a really
really tough question and a great
question we have passed on clients
because of my own personal compass you
know like the Patriots and and we
haven't passed in a picture it's a it's
unfair to them though I still hate you
Patriots but I love vaynernation
Patriot fans I just hate how you roll a
football so the answer is it's starting
to rear its head America has never been
more divided we have we have growing
offices in Middle America which I think
will take away some of the East Coast
West Coast mentality everybody in this
office is divided on things like I mean
should we not take sugar water I mean
that there's plenty people in this
company that think we shouldn't guns I
mean jeez especially with the tragic
events of yesterday in this entire year
and just like the last several years in
America alcohol you know I mean so you
know tobacco I mean what if a the
biggest tobacco company came on and work
with Vayner I think there's plenty of
people here that would have a tough time
working on it would bow out wouldn't
want me to take it on is that my you
know so you know I think I've made those
decisions my whole life for me as a
person it's easy for me it's me I'm
accountable to me
I don't do the sponsored stuff that I
don't want to I don't do any sponsor
stuff but like I've forgiven I've been
thinking a lot about getting a lead
sponsor for the askgaryvee show in 2016
because I need I need and want those
dollars to apply to a lot more
advertising to learn more about growth
of content online I need real dollars so
I've been thinking a lot about that
that's interesting I've never thought
about that before I never did it with
Wine Library things of that nature would
I take any brand absolutely not
you know so I think that you know money
is the last thing that drives me but I
also absolutely have no interest in
idealistic you know over political
correctness dictating my decisions and I
think we have that especially when you
live in New York LA San Francisco and so
I have to think of things as a
collective including a global collective
not just the United States of America
that's my answer
that was real that was real as [ __ ]
sorry I just the d-roc was pretty
amazing
Louie asks what's the best way to deal
with someone who is constantly negative
about entrepreneurship and what if it's
your mom
Louie I I think the biggest way
to handle that is to stick it to your
mom I think you go out and you execute
and then you tell your mom I told you so
you were wrong mom you know what's great
about entrepreneurship the market
business life is it's a net-net game
meaning at the end of the day either
your mom's right or you're right she's
negative about entrepreneurship with you
Louise she doesn't think you can do it I
don't think your mom overarching doesn't
believe that entrepreneurship exists or
as an option she just doesn't believe in
you now I'm drilling you right now
because I'm trying to light a fire in
your ass to be like really pissed the
way I get like nothing excites me more
than the adrenaline that I get right now
I'm fired up for you Louie I'm making
pretend that I'm you Louie and I'm so
goddamn pissed
I want to literally punch my mom in the
face like that's how I feel and so but
like figuratively like I'm not condoning
violence against your mom my mom is my
favorite person on earth my mom is the
complete opposite no one believed in me
more or ever will so that being said
Louie she doesn't she doesn't not
believe in entrepreneurship she doesn't
believe that you're an entrepreneur now
the question is back to my
self-awareness content that I've been
pushing out a lot you maybe she's right
maybe you're delusional right the real
question is who else in your ecosystem
does believe and more importantly forget
about everybody else and this is really
the crux of the whole damn thing do you
believe right because I think one of the
weird things that has happened in my
life that I think has created the
scenarios of my existence is I have an
incredible ability I've had my whole
life to literally tune out every other
voice except my own and I think that
it's equally a vulnerability I have no
mentors for that reason I love my
parents I would give them the mentor
mantle but like I really don't I
literally just listen to my own voice
and so if you're lucky as I am and I
know millions of people are I'm sure to
be able to tune out everybody if you
believe you're an entrepreneur then
you're set I would argue the fact that
you're even asking me this question
means that you put weight into your
mom's opinion which I think needs to be
dissected by you to begin with because I
put zero weight into anybody's opinion
about myself because I know exactly who
I am
B is that BA no I know I just want to
say B yay
go ahead B asks what do you think of
McDonald's response to Burger King's
peace mcwhopper idea seems like they
missed a big opportunity
dear ox before I answer this are you
running the b-roll that we did before
the show yeah to start the show right
now no start start the show with it I
think I'll be interesting people gonna
be o stefan's now right Stefan
graduating to editing the show start
with all that b-roll old black-and-white
before it even goes into it cuz then
people understand why I screwed up the
intro cuz that transition was awkward uh
I well first of all you've seen a lot of
our banter on this I'm with you India I
thought it was I think I think my answer
came through in the black and white that
started the show which is I think
McDonald's I think McDonald's personal I
like competition so I like the
McDonald's kind of same Burger King
right back
you know Burger King tried to like win
the game by being like like there was
McDonald's was in a very tough spot I I
also love what Burger King is doing in
marketing right now I think they're
being very clever sonic is one of our
great clients at vaynermedia so you know
I've got that hat on I think it's super
fun to watch I think I'll answer this we
are clearly living in interesting times
where Burger King can make a micro site
to make this announcement and McDonald's
official answer is in a Facebook post in
sentence form if you haven't realized
that communication has changed forever
in our society please let this be a
moment where this is how companies that
are dead heated compat me Pepsi coke
like burning with that it doesn't get
more than that I think that I think it
just depends on what side you want to be
on there's the people that always want
to be on the serious side which
McDonald's wins there's a people that
think the world is way too serious and
you need a little humor you know I think
more people sit on that other side hence
why I think that was popular reply to
McDonald's and up voted for me for me I
I like the way they went with it but I
can see every angle of it I like that
Burger King didn't I like the women I
just want them to fight like if you
really want me you know listen but you
understand I'm keeping my interest to me
as a person I love competition
I live for companies fighting with each
other and trying to beat each other
jockey and chess moves and death I love
it the sport of it just like politics
has become a sport at entertainment
which has a lot of sad variables around
that I think business is about to go
that way because everybody can
communicate and it's all in public and
all this stuff so you know I'm just
enjoying watching just pass me the
popcorn this head full battery on this
whole line of it so what's happening
fine we're still bowling no Philby
there'll be a lack of a continuous
stream
I got a row no more like right now
there'll be a pop some sort of pause
right here yeah right the little feel
they'll feel like a little click right
out right I'll use it we're gonna gun
pinion are you gonna use this I can cuz
I have says use it guys
you saw what happened I'm Stefan you
really really you really earning your
keep today you saw it how I'm so pumped
you saw it happen d-roc didn't like last
time when we talked about the audio
breaking out on him and he was super sad
and we liked d-roc there we did the
whole thing and see there it is I love
it all captured great job Stefan
can't seem to get myself to commit what
joining start doing to learn
two things cable first of all three
things please do not record while
driving ever again in your life please
God please number two by the way I know
some people jump in me like Aaron you
did a car selfie the other day yes at a
red light
hardcore red light and even that's not
great cuz you know if somebody's like
coming to drill you but where you going
anyway nonetheless two things under this
plan it is learned behavior you just
have to start doing it right it's just
learned behavior you have to start doing
it there's nothing else you have to
start doing it now the question becomes
it's a chicken-and-egg game I think the
only way you can learn to hustle and
work this hard is by actually loving it
I could never do anything I don't love
at this rigor and vigor like it's just
impossible it's impossible and so
figuring out what you love to do and
then and then just making it learn
behavior I would tell you my teen here I
know all of them I've watched them all
in the short period of time they're all
faster than they used to be they're
faster learn behavior the speed in which
my team works even versus the way India
could probably speak to this the best
even to the speed that vaynermedia works
which is every person that comes to
veiners like this companies fast but the
way we work is even faster it's just the
truth
so it's learned behavior you can get
faster you can be you can work harder
but it's learned behavior the only way
to really do it is you gotta love it so
that's it it's real simple it's really
that's the answer in my opinion one
man's point of view
chad asks with everything that you do is
there anything that you feel you need to
start doing uh I need to start hacking
more day-in and day-out time with the
kids I've been talking about this out
loud I'm a smoke work where there's
smoke there's fire
I wish I did this show one year earlier
because that whole year I would have
talked about health the show started
right as I started taking care of my
house I was ready in it you guys have
been hearing me talking about going home
taking the bath with them or dinner with
them this is me selling myself what I'm
really good at is I keep pounding myself
into submission when something doesn't
come natural and so I need to hack more
time with the kids is nay they get to
six
three now there were six and three now
they're really really there's things you
know and I'm going to the recital and
this and that but I want more day-in and
day-out time I've been winning on
extremities it's worked but now I need
to figure out more opportunities to
spend that hour minimum a day with them
walking to school bath dinner together
it's gonna be hard because I'm really a
continuous guy like I could start and
then I just go breaking up the day where
I have to shut off the intensity that I
live with you understand the speed at
which my brain is activated and the
hyper sensitive nature of how I roll
when I'm in my game when I'm that was me
putting on a helmet on the field which
is when I start my day I don't stop it
that's why I don't eat lunch I'm just on
and so to stop that defrag really give
you know so many of you were spending
hours with your kids and loved lines
ones but you're not spending real time
real time is mentally being in it you
know checking the box that you like what
you you took your kid to baseball
practice but you looked at your phone
the whole time was not being in it my
friends so I need to be in it right and
to shut down at 5:00 p.m.
what's been going on for you know eight
hours give in to like listening
consuming engaging and then restart
because that's what's gonna happen it's
gonna be a real challenge for me and I
need to do more of that cool what uh tip
right cool cool
what's your statement of the day not
having this questions a lot of fun
what's your stake by the way the
statements is are really working I read
all the comments on YouTube and Facebook
late last night went to sleep at like
three in the morning and it really gave
me context to what you guys are thinking
I'm using your feedback loops as ways to
to make the show better but it's also
really great because watching you guys
leave your statement of the day versus
kind of a question of the day is there's
so much more profound content now in the
comments section which allows all of you
to learn from each other and more
community it's less about me it's more
about us and that's where I'm going with
it if you are curious you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
[Music]